hey guys what is going on welcome to the
18th scikit-learn with python for
machine learning and our practical
example of
using machine learning for investing
in this video we're going to be doing is
using the stock file that we just
created in the last video
my apologies that probably took at least
it took me about 45 minutes to an hour
to pull all those prices
this is the file that it comes down into
and i will just say in the past there
was a way to do these things called the
uh man i can't even think of a word but
it was from from cuando a superset so
you could pass through just a ton of
data and get a superset
and
there's another way by a quandl to pass
through a bunch of
i guess tickers or whatever and get them
all at the same time that would have
been faster but i was not sure how you
can do that and modify
the column because we needed each column
we only need one column from that data
set and we needed each column
to
be the ticker
and
luckily we just need to do that poll one
time so it's not a big deal there might
be somewhere on quandl the entire data
set of the s p 500 adjusted close or you
know whatever um
i don't know it so if it exists let me
know
and maybe let some of the other people
know in the previous video anyway here's
the file uh so we've got uh you know the
date which is our index in theory and
then all of the companies that we were
able to pull so some companies uh the
data just did not exist and uh it was
not pulled but
that's okay this will do
yeah so i'm not quite sure why uh toyota
was one of them that didn't pull anyways
uh so i'm not really sure why some of
them pulled and some of them didn't the
data just really wasn't there it wasn't
an http error
anyway uh moving along not really too
worried about that at least for this
tutorial in its consideration so so
that's all these are all the you know
each row basically in each row is a day
and then we go all the way down to
where we pulled at the very very bottom
looks like a lot of missed data there
anyway uh closing out of this and this
uh we're ready to begin so here we are
going to take the exact same stuff from
tutorial part 12. so this is the part 12
script if you don't have it for whatever
reason
eventually you know we're going to have
basically kind of i guess two major
scripts right you've got the data
polling script and you've got the
machine learning script
and then you know our training and
testing scripts so to speak but anyway
this is from the
tutorial number 12.
so this was the last
data creation
script that we wrote so i'm just going
to do ctrl a ctrl c ctrl v
and copy it into here if you don't have
it you can add to
pythonprogramming.net go to machine
learning and
go to part 12 and this will be here
it may not always be categories that way
but go to python program.net and you'll
find it um and if you need a link to
part 12 just let me know and i'll link
you if you can't find it
so
uh to begin uh our first change doesn't
really occur until basically here we've
got s p 500 df and now we need to add
stock underscore df and that's going to
equal for me
dot pd.dataframe.from
underscore csv
and the csv name that we called it was
stock underscore prices.csv
okay so that's where we find uh the file
now um
i guess i had maybe no
i thought for some reason i i hadn't
gone all the way through all the stocks
but we have so now we want to do is see
before we were grabbing like the
starting and stopping stuff we don't
actually need that so i'm going to
comment this out
uh because we're not going to use that
anymore and i apologize in advance the
first time through this script may not
work
just because there's a lot of like
manhandling that we're going to be doing
here but
anyway continuing on
we're going to come all the way down
to
basically
right here so
the s p 500 values we're pulling that
already from the file that we got from
quandl so we don't need to modify that
but now we need a new variable and it's
going to be one underscore year
underscore later
and one year later is going to equal
the integer value of the unix time
plus
uh what is that number it'll be
three one five
three six zero zero zero so what does
that make this
yeah 31 millions 0.5 seconds
anyway so that's taking the unix time
which we're pulling way up here from
because each each data file is stored by
the year month day hours minute seconds
and then we ended up converting it to
unix time so we're just taking that unix
time and we're saying hey a year from
that unix time is whatever that time is
plus this and that'll give us a unix
stamp of one year later
so
once we've done that
we're going to want to pull
the s p 500 information from a year
later and while i'm here
um
[Music]
i'm gonna go ahead and delete all of
this
and i'll scroll back down to where i was
so this try and gathering of stock price
and then basically all the way down to
this if not starting stock value that
stuff we commented all that out so all
of that and i'm just gonna delete that
okay
and
um
and now i guess we'll begin this custom
code so anyway uh so one year later and
then we're gonna have this try
and then we're going to have an accept
exception as e
and then in here we'll have another try
and accept exception as e
like this cool so the first thing that
we're going to try is we're going to say
sp 500 underscore one year
equals uh
let's see date time and then we're going
to string from time that
information so we're going to say date
time dot from time stamp
and then we're going to say one
whoops
basically one year later this
dot from time stamp one year later and
then let me just scroll up here
dot string from
time
and then it's percent actually let's
just uh copy this right here
so it's that
and then
um
i think we can maybe get away with just
cut let's just copy this
paste that and then the row
is equal to
[Music]
uh
that
and then instead of s p 500 date it
should be s p 500 one year
good good good
just check in just check in and then
instead of uh value will go underscore
one year
value
just one more look before we move on
this is kind of a hacky jobs uh
hopefully i don't mess anything up
anyway so we try that and if that fails
uh then we want to try
this
same same same code
and the only change is that minus you
know a couple days basically so accept
exception as e we're not going to really
call an exception there um
and so one year later minus two five
nine two hundred
so that that subtracts a few days so
hopefully we can get the price that way
uh row sp 500 value cool
so
oh oops my mistake
we need to take this uh cut that and we
need to put it a try i knew that that
was looking funky to me i knew i was
doing something wrong
so we do this
okay so we try that
and exception
[Music]
um if we hit an exception for whatever
reason
uh we'll just say
s p 500
wow i can't type
exception
e okay
um we can do stringy i've never had a
case where e didn't work but stringy i
always see stringy being done
i suppose if it it might be like unicode
or something like that and people want
to save it or i don't know so anyway
boom done now we want to do the stock
prices and we might as well um
you know we get the stock price from
um the page but like i was saying that's
not adjusted price right so if the stock
has a stock split like in apple's case
um
we're not accounting for that because
we're pulling because the data that
we're pulling from yahoo as historical
it's as if we parsed yahoo every day
in real time that day so
um anything like stock splits won't be
accounted for and that's a huge problem
so
uh so we'll come down here
and so basically this is getting us our
s p 500 one year later and we were
already pulling our s p 500 data
from a reliable source so we don't have
to rewrite that code now we're going to
rewrite or we're going to write one year
later stock price codes so we would say
try
and then basically have the same kind of
try accept try
accept and then really exception as e
the first one we didn't really need
uh print
stock price one year later
uh
string
e
fix that okay
so
uh the stock price what we're going to
basically say
is um
i guess we can really
i hate to do this but we can really just
let's just actually take this copy
paste
and then instead of s p 500 we're going
to say that stock price and now we
change this to stock under whoops stock
underscore price underscore one year
equals uh
okay so that gets us our one year data
then
um
row
equals
uh
suppose stock underscore df
and then the stock underscore df where
stock underscore df.index
equals stock price one year so that's
where the index right which is the date
equals the date we're looking for and
then
uh instead of sp 500 value we'll just
say stock one year value equals float
row adjusted close
then we can take this exact same
bit of information paste it here we'll
have to tab these two rows over whoops
highlight them tab them over
uh then we do minus this value so
subtract that from there
now we're cooking
okay so that's our stock price one year
later
and then now we just need to get the
stock price
so again we'll come down here
and
um
really stock price but basically we'll
copy this we'll just copy this
uh it will come down
paste
and instead of stock price one year
we're going to call this stock price and
instead of one year later we're going to
use unix underscore
time
string from time cool stock price will
equal the same as before right stock df
where
stock df index equals
stock price
flat
and then stock
value like that and actually you know
what we use stock price later in the
script so let's say actually stock price
not stock value equals float
row adjusted then we'll take this
highlight that copy that
paste
tab that over
and then we'll do again the minus value
there
oh okay
this is like always the hardest part for
me like manipulating a script it almost
always goes wrong and then i like i end
up just like scrapping the entire thing
and just rewriting it
and it's probably better than doing what
i'm doing here but that's okay
um so let me let's just look one more
time before we run this
uh stop price date time from time to
stand
and if you're as confused or if you feel
like you got lost i usually post up the
code within a few days of posting the
video so if you are confused or
something just like look for it
on
pythonprogramming.net but uh this looks
to me like we're going to get it so
uh we do this we run blah blah blah blah
blah let me make sure on the original
that i wrote here
okay so i think we're ready to move
along
so then we come down to
these two values and we still want them
but they're changed a little bit so
stock percentage change percentage
change always works new minus the old
divided by the old times 100
so stock p change will be stock price
one year because that's in theory the
new so stock price underscore one year
uh minus
stock price so new minus the old
divided by the old
times 100 and then again here
uh
s p 500 change will be s p 500
underscore
one year underscore
value
is that what let's see hold up
yeah so stock one year value
okay coming down here so stock one of
your value new minus the old divided by
the old times 100 s p 500 one year value
minus
isn't that is that really called i think
we just called it s p 500 value yeah so
so back down here
new minus the old divided by the old
times 100 so sp 500 minus s p 500 value
divided by s p 500 value
uh
times 100
cool
uh the next thing i want to go ahead and
have us do here is we want to have see
like this is all basically like this uh
what we want to do now is we're going to
encase all of this in their own as its
own little operation so let's do that
really quick
and then oops and then we are going to
have a round operation so we're going to
round
this whoops round this
to the nearest two decimal places and
then we're gonna do the same freaking
thing again
round whoops round to the nearest two
decimal places because we might end up
with some really long decimals and that
takes up a lot of data especially when
you have a bunch of rows a bunch of
stocks and if you have a bunch of you
know data points it doesn't necessarily
help accuracy it depends i suppose on
you know what kind of uh
range we're looking at but in the case
of this where stocks are you know in the
teens to hundreds uh going to the you
know thousandth or millionth data point
is worthless so we've got that
now difference
will
stay the same
and then the question is if difference
is greater than zero outperform else
underperform
that's fine then we're going to ask if
value lists not available
that's all fine and dandy
so then we're going to come to the very
bottom and we're going to say key stats
and we're going to call this now
acc for accurate performance
um
accurate performance underscore no
underscore n a because we're not
allowing any column to
contain
not available
right that's what this line is doing for
us
so we'll save one of each and we can
test on one of each
soon so uh that's that let's go ahead
and save and run it and see hopefully we
get something printed out but hopefully
we don't have any errors
okay so definitely having an error
um
okay so we're having s p 500 error and
what appears to be stock price error
coming up here
so s p 500 exception okay so we're
hitting that exception and we're hitting
a stock price
exception
okay
so
the
problem that's interesting so my my val
version
that i check here
yeah
okay
uh i'm not sure about the s p 500
exception that's kind of a strange
exception that we're throwing i'm
not quite expecting that
uh so let's solve this s p 500 exception
then we'll go to the stock i see i know
what i've done wrong with the stock but
string indices must be integers
it's just really com
complicated because
i mean we're doing the exact same thing
here right i mean aren't we
because like this is working
or so i believe
we could be hitting this final exception
maybe
because that final exception is a pass
uh
let let's do um
just real quick let's add a try and
accept to this one
try except
exception as e
string e
that's plenty of time to get our
i don't know about y'all i don't see any
blasts
okay
so
what's odd is
these two blocks of code for the s p 500
are are nearly identical obviously
there's um some sort of change
one year later can't really be it i
don't think
[Music]
the problem is also
i'm not really sure
you know looking at oh i guess we closed
out the air
okay
sp5 string indices
must be integers
so
i would assume
[Music]
that
okay so we're hitting it here
i mean i would assume that that's
talking about this right here
um but i mean we're we're calling that
to occur
um
we could i suppose just like redo this
this one um
okay let's try it one more time
uh so stop let's see we come up here s p
underscore
one year
equals date time
one year later
in unix time plus
31 that should be
acceptable
says is acceptable
so i believe that's acceptable sp500
equals that one year later from
timestamp rho equals sp500
that's totally fine where the index
equals
s p 500 one year
finally sp 500
underscore one year underscore value
ought to equal
that
cool
highlight this
come down here
let us paste
tab
and then we'll do minus 259 200.
500 one year a later issue
saving one
you're really pissed if i see that again
i don't see it again i don't know about
y'all
maybe one of them came through but
that's okay
uh it's probably a missing value or
something okay so
i don't know what i missed the first
time around but that seemed the easiest
fix seemed to be to retry now coming to
stock price let's see if i already
forgot what it was okay so with stock
price the problem is our data set does
not it doesn't have adjusted close right
we renamed adjusted close to be the
ticker dot upper
so
to handle for that
we're going to
look where the stock underscore df
doesn't equal stock price
uh no so the value what we're looking
for is where the row let's see row
and then
we should be able to do this
what where row
equals um
hold on let me consult the original here
stock df and then
stock price one year
stock price
so
what we'll do instead uh equals
so we'll call the row here and then what
we'll add to this is ticker dot upper
like that so this
actually is our stock value for the most
part and then we're going to say the
stock one year value is the float
value
of
a row
like that
and
we're going to go ahead and round this
as well round
float
row
now
um oh wait float
and then we'll round that to the nearest
uh two decimal places
my brain is telling me i'm done after
this video so most likely done
there's just something about like
manipulating pre-existing code to serve
a new purpose or to do something new
that just i don't know just makes my
brain want to blow
uh
so stock price is gonna the same thing
is gonna happen down here so
um
so
we said
basically this does this line doesn't
change
well this line changes wow they both
mother trucker
mother trucker okay so we'll just do
this
and the final value is actually stock
underscore price like that
paste
and then highlight this the final thing
is stock
underscore price
okay so that is still
i think
that's good and my head is about to
explode i think my allergies are kicking
into or something i got a massive
headache coming on
oh gosh we still got this stupid
looks like too many errors to me
it's okay to get a couple errors but
nobody likes a billion okay cannot
convert series to class floats
jerks
this isn't a series though row is that a
row should actually be a value um
okay
oh man my brain is dying today okay okay
that's okay
we'll get there get there man
[Music]
uh so we'll call the first
okay so this is our first stock price in
one year um let's go ahead and print row
real quick just to see what we're
working with i
don't theory that should have done it
but
okay
so it's an empty data frame but we have
all these columns
i swear this came up before but i'm
looking at the code that i've used and i
don't really see anything different
[Music]
oh wait a second
so yeah so we accounted for the ticker
upper here but not there
okay
now
i might not make it through this video
guys i might just have a stroke or
something okay stock price
okay so this is the regular stock price
that we've accounted for here the ticker
upper
flow blah blah blah
come here
we just didn't account for it i guess so
the one year value copy
paste there
okay we should be returned a number
a
nothing float 64 for the data type let's
uh
let's close this real quick
we're going to come down here now cut
paste
and instead of uh
copy
paste
so we'll print out the stock one year
value
finally okay
uh now close out of this
and we'll comment this out
okay
moment of truth everyone
no errors please
oh
that's fine
slow enough to not scare me too much we
should have like probably some some s p
500 and some stock price errors but
we'll see you soon
blackberry no surprise bmc
berkshire
see blackberry was
a research in motion for a while and
then they switched basically cnx no idea
burke b
that's berkshire um i'm guessing
berkshire class b
probably the dash might be different
between the stocks
i think that file just wasn't even
pulled a lot of these might be files
that weren't polled i think by the time
we're done
all like compatible data i think we get
down we start from like about 500 and
i don't know like 550 stocks and we get
whittled down to i think 350 or
something just based on missed data
josby
i think joe's b went out of business or
did they go private i can't even
remember
um
so we're only unlimited i hope i'm
hoping i can chit-chat long enough to
get to the end of this and check our
file and make sure everything worked and
then we'll probably once this is done uh
pulling i think it normally takes about
40 seconds or so once that's done
pulling the next thing we would do is we
haven't we've pulled a not available
version now we'll pull a
including some not available data so we
can come down here it says is if value
list is uh or if yeah if the amount of
not availables is greater than zero
we've been tossing it
well now let's allow up to 15. so we
don't want the majority of the data to
be not available but we should we're
going to allow for some not available
data
so we allow for that and then we'll
scroll down here and then we'll just
call this you know with n a in all caps
save that
and
um
after this i guess is done okay it looks
like it's done oh my goodness what if
okay i thought that was the
i thought that was a data frame error
and i was like no at the very end it
like quits
um so we are going to here
and the name of our data frame
was
okay so it looks like i was attempting
to lead you all astray
so we have to make one more quick fix i
only figured this out after i had run it
um and noticed
that we were we were getting actually
one or actually i'm sorry it was like 99
accuracy
so there was something wrong and uh the
problem was everything was being uh
labeled as underperformance
and
so therefore as we trained it it
basically said base you know everything
is underperformed
so
uh we had like a 99.8 percent accuracy
which is obviously flawed so
um
the problem is in this line here so
in the
block of code where we
get the value of stock price
um not stock price underscore one year
it's stock price if you come down here
you'll see that what we're doing when we
define row we're defining row because we
had copy and pasted from this block up
here when we define row we're saying the
row equals stock df where the index is
the same as the stock price
one year so what was happening is for
the percentage change of the stocks it
was zero it was always a zero percentage
change
after one year so as you can imagine
only time it would ever outperform the s
p 500 would be
maybe around like you know 2007 2008 ish
when the market was you know falling
so
because it needed to be
you the market needed over the course of
one year from any given point needed to
be lower so
anyway
that was the problem so now we're going
to go ahead and just fix this so this
needs to be uh just stock let's see
stock price right
so just stock price and stock price and
now
this should be good to run um hopefully
so anyways i'm gonna go ahead and hit
down and run this this this process
takes usually like just like a minute or
something so
um and in fact make sure you got rid of
the print statements uh initially we
were printing out the price and don't
don't want to do that either
i don't think so
okay so anyway run that and you'll be
ready to proceed into the next video as
always if you guys have any questions or
comments feel free to leave them below
otherwise as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and the donations and
until next time
[Music]